all right everybody
and so
um I got kovid on the way back from uh
Jerusalem so I'm feeling a little bit
under the weather but um since then the
video with Muhammad hijab has come out
and uh
for me that video was just another day
in the week with Jordan he asked me in
last minute to come and to participate
and now I'm seeing that it's creating a
huge amount of reaction and I've
received quite a number of emails from
several people from all kinds of people
people that are angry with the way I
reacted people that are happy with where
I reacted Christians that it felt like I
didn't defend the Trinity enough and
Muslims which who are apologizing for
Muhammad hijab and saying that he is not
a representative of uh any kind of Islam
that they think is is intelligent
um and so
I thought maybe I'd give a few thoughts
about the event and uh how why I was
reacting the way I was and uh yeah so
let's let's do this
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
so the first thing to understand is this
was not an event that I plan to do
Jordan invited me the day before he said
why don't you come talk to this guy
Muhammad hijab I didn't really know who
he was and so I went online and uh all I
found were videos of him in the street
with masked men you know saying how
they're gonna fight off whoever comes to
get them videos of him in the street you
know saying that if these Jews come out
with their dogs again we're going to
kill their dogs those are the videos
that I saw uh of him and so I was like
who is this guy and why are we meeting
with him there were a lot of people
warning us we went to dinner the day
before and there were a lot of people
warning us saying we shouldn't meet with
him
um and so you know whatever you know
I'll do I'll do whatever I'm not uh I'm
not scared of I'm not afraid I mean it
was fine we'll just go meet with this
guy that's fine I've had
stranger things in my life so we went to
meet him and
I realized very quickly in the
discussion that all this person really
cared about was converting us to Islam
he really did not want to have a
discussion he did not want to have uh he
did not want to listen to what we were
saying he just wanted to uh convert US
to Islam we just wanted to convince us
and my understanding was that the this
the purpose of the discussion was to
talk about
uh the place of Jesus in Islam and how
there could be some discussion about
that and see how there's overlap you
know I think Jordan was hoping to find
some common ground but obviously that
was not what was happening all this
person was doing was trying to convince
us of becoming Muslim but that's not the
only thing that was going on there was
another thing going on was that he
really wasn't trying to convert US to
Islam he was trying to convince his
buddies in the room that he was trying
to convert US to Islam that was what
that's what was making the whole thing
even stranger because when he started
talking about what Christians believed I
had to laugh I was just smiling sitting
there watching him because no Christian
would recognize themselves in what he
was describing Christianity to be no
Christian would would recognize
themselves in what he was describing the
Trinity to be or the Incarnation or
anything that he was describing about
Christianity he was presenting to us the
wildest caricature of what Christians
believe and then he was trying to mock
it or refute it and so that's when I
realized that he really wasn't even
talking to us he was talking to his
fellow Muslims
trying to gain clout and trying to make
himself more important by proving to
them and showing to them that here he
was he was the tough guy Muslim and he
was going to you know tell us about what
Islam is and it was going to convert US
to Islam so how do you react to
something like that you know how can you
sit there for two hours and look someone
in the eye and realize this person isn't
engaging with me at all this person
isn't listening to me or to Jordan or to
anybody he's not even actually trying to
communicate anything in a way that he's
hoping that will connect with me he's
just trying to open the valve and and
you know and just shoot out his prefab
scent prefab arguments and
his prefab prefab arguments in our faces
until the conversation was over and so
to be honest I was just sitting there
going what are we doing here like what
is happening and I and so I didn't say
much because what was I going to say I
was like going to start arguing with
this guy about the Trinity I mean let's
be honest after the discussion when we
were having lunch
I provoked him a little bit I said you
know Muhammad the version of the Trinity
that you proposed to us was quite a
caricature and he said of course it
wasn't a caricature I took it straight
out from the Apollo's Creed
and I was like really okay you know it's
like I guess we're getting our theology
from Rocky 2 now but I mean I get it
look I'm not even criticizing him I
don't know that much about Islam and so
you know I probably would be making
those mistakes as well if I was trying
to to kind of preach to to Muslims and
trying to convert Muslims but as you
notice I don't do that because I don't
feel like I know enough about Islam all
I try to do is try to present the things
that I've understood and the things that
I have intuitions about and that's what
I'm interested in doing but but uh but
so if you want to understand why I was
reacting the way I was
that is what was going on now if you
want to talk about the Trinity I am not
the greatest expert on the Trinity I've
actually said that many times but I
understand enough about the Trinity to
to think that it is not the ridiculous
caricature that was presented to us so
maybe we can just talk a little bit
about why the Trinity is so important
for Christians and why the Incarnation
is so important for Christians uh and
and maybe can help some people
understand I don't know I mean it seems
like the things I'm going to say maybe
are going to be completely obvious to
Christians and I won't be even talking
to anybody because I'm pretty sure that
that the the Muslims uh that are on
Muhammad hijab side won't be watching
this video anyway so let's do it we'll
see what happens uh and so
the question about the trinity
the question about the Trinity has a lot
to do with the problem of Duality and
the problem of how is it that God can
have a relationship with us
in Christian terms what is mostly
worried about or what we care about is
the question of whether something is
created or uncreated and so we have the
sense in which God is uncreated he's not
made and his dep his existence is not
uh you know his existence is not
dependent on anything and then we have
creation which is made and whose
existence is dependent on the infinite
is dependent on God who is the source of
all things and of all being and so
these are the two categories that we
deal with now so when we ask ourselves
what is God or what aspects that we see
in scripture in Revelation that is God
what we're asking ourselves and what
what is created and what is what is
uncreated what is not created and the
the conclusion to which the church
fathers came to is that the word by
which God created the world the one that
is presented in Genesis 1 and that is
presented also in the first the the
first book of John
is not a creation
it is God himself it is God's word it is
not something that God made it is not a
it is not a creation it it is God's word
and that God's spirit which we see in
Genesis 1 that the spirit that hovers
above the waters the spirit of God is
God's spirit it is not created it is not
something that God has made it is an
actual it is something which is related
directly to God now of course the way to
formulate it I can understand why some
people find it difficult because some of
the terms are obviously technical uh
because we're trying to talk about
something which is very very difficult
but nonetheless the problem that you
have with the the problem of monotheism
or the problem with the God is that if
you're not careful what you're going to
end up having and so imagine that you
say when God speaks his speech his word
is created it is no longer God as soon
as God speaks it is no longer God as
soon as God you know
um extend them extends himself into the
world then it is no longer God and so
what you have is you have this divide
that is so radical between God and the
world that there is no possible
relationship between God and the world
and that that is not just a problem in
terms of terms of like let's say
sentimentality in terms of thinking like
okay so God creates us and we have no
relationship with him it's actually a
more technical problem which is that
where is the world then
is the world where does the word world
exist did God create something
completely outside of him so now there's
God and there's this thing creation
which has a completely separate
existence from him well no
I think that even even Muslims would
believe that the world is dependent on
God but to in what way is the world
dependent on God how is the how does
this how is this dependence possible and
the man in which that the Christians
have seen in the revelation of scripture
and in the Revelation that they that
they have that they've gone from God is
that the Trinity is
is the manner in which God Appears to us
as love and that this love is that which
fills the world and so the Orthodox for
example will go even further than just
the Trinity we say that the God's
energies that is that the actions of God
in the world are God they are not they
are not created and so underlying
actually all of creation are God's
energies which are God himself which are
not a diminished version of God they're
not like a lower form of angel or a
lower form of being but they are God
himself and so this what it does is that
it means that Christianity is ultimately
an extremely mystical form of religion
it means that Christianity is a religion
in which the the very existence of the
world is shimmering with the presence of
God everything that exists is has a
spark hidden behind behind it or inside
it which is God himself and it doesn't
mean that things are Gods nobody
believes that it doesn't mean that that
objects in the world are God but that
underlying the cause of all things is
this Divine spark the action of God
behind it
and The Trinity has that same aspect it
means that when God pours himself out
into the world it is God that is pouring
himself out it is not some lower form of
God it is not like in the Gnostic
systems where the world is created by a
lower form of God what that does is it
creates this strict strict strict
hierarchy where beings the lower they
are the further they are from God the
less they have you know the the less
ontological existence that they have and
the more they are evil so often in these
in a lot of systems where they don't
where they're not able to create a
bridge between God and the world like
what is the bridge between God and the
world if you if they for a lot of the
systems that can't find that bridge they
have the problem of understanding the
world as fallen or the world is evil in
itself because it's not connected to God
how is it connected to God and so one of
the aspects that the Trinity does is
that when God speaks it is not a lower
lesser aspect it is not something which
is away from him it is it is God himself
that speaks and his spirit that is that
movement out from God and back into God
right this movement out and back into
God is God himself and so sometimes it's
for it said something like that God
speaks the speaks and his speech is God
and even the space between his speech
and himself is God right his Spirit
which binds his speech to himself is God
and so Christians believe that there is
only one God God the father but that his
word
is fully fully fully God but it's not
it's not also can I say this so we say
it's a specific hypothesis
because we also we also see that
Multiplicity
how does the multiplicity exist one of
the same problems is that one of the
problems of seeing God as a fully as a
full monad and seeing for example his
characteristics as lesser than him is
you have the same problem you always
have the same problem of creating a
world which is in some ways evil or
lesser or or you know that isn't in any
ways connected to God and so by having
three hypotheses these are three
it's hard to find a word because as soon
as you you the word we say three persons
but of course these words are analogies
they're not they're not if you if you
use a person the way that you understand
it now and you've tried to limit it to
that you have to use it as a kind of
springboard to understand
to understand the more of God but the
notion that there are three persons you
could say something like mediates the
space of God I don't know how else to
say it mediates the space of God that is
God gives his divinity to the son gives
it his divinity to his word in his
spirit and so the word is different from
the father it's not the father but it is
fully the father has fully given all of
his divinity into the word and so what
it does is it mediates the the the
difference between God and creation
ultimately it makes it possible for
multiplicity to exist because it is not
an easy question to understand how is it
that multiplicity exists if we
understand a kind of
absolute unity and absolute Multiplicity
in God then the problem goes away and
it's not a multiplicity of contradiction
it's a multiplicity in love it's perfect
love is the best way to understand the
nature of God as Christians understand
it
that it what it does is it gives reason
and it gives vision for why the world
exists and how it exists now
if you the best thing you can get I
think if you don't have
a sense of this in your theology is that
all we exist for
is to worship that's all we exist for
and I and to be honest I've seen Muslims
say that it's like you exist to worship
that's your job get on your knees and
worship
and it's interesting and and you can see
how in Christianity at least the
Christianity that I that I care about we
are meant to worship god of course we
are meant to worship God but that in
that worship God calls us to participate
in him that our ultimate goal or
ultimate
resting place is to be United fully and
completely with God and to even become
deified to that to the extent that
that's possible and that is actually the
reason for creation and so God in his
absolute unity and absolute multiplicity
has this outpouring of Love out of which
creation is made and then this callback
into himself which is this this
this vision of how all things can be
full full of God and be transparent and
glorious in in the finality and so I
mean that is why the Trinity is so
important in Christianity and it's not a
it's not a detail it's not something
that we should
that we should that that I know some
Christians sometimes are ashamed of it
and kind of shy away from it but it is
extremely important to understand the
problem of believing in multiplicity and
what it means to have only one God and
multiplicity without something which
mediates that multiplicity it's very you
know like I said you're gonna have some
you're gonna have some issues in
justifying all that but
the thing that was interesting for sure
in that discussion and and the reason
why to be honest in the end I wasn't
I wasn't really angry I was just kind of
surprised as I found myself in a
situation that was similar to the
situation that I grew up in which is
that I grew up in certain circumstances
not everybody I've said often that it
wasn't like that in my family but in the
churches I grew up in and some people
that I still care about very much today
have this attitude of looking for every
opportunity to evangelize you to look
for every opportunity to give you the
message in a way that is at some point
even I think
destroys the relationship or ignores the
true relationship that can exist between
two humans you know I remember when I
was young even hearing someone when I
brought up the fact that God says to
love our neighbor
um that the answer was yes to love your
neighbor is to evangelize them that is
how you love your neighbor and so it's
something that I've known quite well
that I known quite well my whole life
and that I grew up with
um and so you know I just felt like I
was sitting in that moment again and to
be honest there's no way that I was
going to engage in the in in the kind of
debate in a situation where the person
in front of you is not listening to you
in any way and really doesn't
doesn't want to know what you think just
wants you to listen to their preaching
and so
that's that and so I hope this was
helpful to maybe help people understand
a little bit you know why it is that I
reacted the way that I did and sorry for
my coveted voice here
hopefully I'll be better next week and
uh and we'll have a
and we'll have a less scratchy videos so
thanks everybody and I'll talk to you
very soon